dites-moi ce que vous pensez,
je pense que nous devrions d'abord faire le test, qu'est-ce que
vous jouez sur ce violon d'une seconde,
n'avez-vous pas envie de jouer
la partie solo de temps en temps,
bien sûr, j'ai parlé avec le docteur Nader de
cette difficulté que j'ai  j'ai la
maladie de Parkinson, dit-elle,
j'aimerais que le premier concert de la saison
soit mon adieu, alors il est préférable que le
quatuor
planifie à l'avance
je ne veux plus jouer exclusivement du deuxième violon
mais il ne s'agit pas de
toi
ou de la sourdine, non, c'est  pas le quatuor pourquoi
n'as-tu pas mon sac à dos
peux-tu arrêter le taxi s'il te plaît ne
commençons pas par l'opus 131 de Beethoven
il a sept mouvements et ils sont tous
connectés
pour nous cela signifie jouer sans pause j'adore
jouer avec toi quand tu  tu ne peux pas diriger un
quatuor, tu n'es pas suffisant tu
penses que
tu es mieux pas motivé pas de repos
pas de réglage penses-
tu que c'était amusant de grandir avec
deux joueurs de quatuor tissés pour des parents
qui étaient partis sept mois de l'année où
j'ai fait le  Du mieux que j'ai pu, j'ai essayé d'
être une bonne mère pour toi,
nos instruments doivent, avec le temps, se
désaccorder chacun à sa manière très différente,
je t'aime plus que tout au
monde, j'ai fait une erreur stupide,
il essayait peut-être de me le faire remarquer.  une certaine
cohésion une certaine unité entre des
actes aléatoires de la vie est-ce que tu m'aimes vraiment
ou est-ce que je suis juste pratique qu'est-ce que
tu veux qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te dise de quoi as-tu
peur libère ta
passion
que sommes-nous censés faire arrêter  ou
avoir du mal
à s'adapter continuellement l'un à l'autre
jusqu'à la fin
même si nous ne sommes pas d'accord,
je ne vous connais pas